non mais qui doit venir des gens
derrière lui et demi eric zemmour ils
ont emmené des gens derrière eux ils ont
parlé aux français tous les soirs en
leur disant pendant la campagne on va
vous sortir de là on va vous m'en donnez
une vie meilleure vous allez voir la
france sera plus belle avec nous vous
allez voir l'oeil sait même plus où là
il sait pas si la tpm pays s'est passé
là-bas c'est pathétique non mais je
trouve ça très grave c'est très grave
c'est très mou ça très très loin d'avoir
menti aux gens étant d'abord normalement
vous devriez rester dans la politique
coûte que coûte pour sauver le soul dans
un truc
ça leur plaise
ou non moi j'ai pas de problème ce
voyage s'est engagé dans la politique et
je n'ai pas réussi et ne je dis juste
que quand on promet aux français normand
on les lâche pas là vous partez
l'histoire nous mêmes gestes que nous
progressons bien régner en cinq sud on
s'en sert naturellement comment tu vas
choyait bienveillant moi si je suis
malade en soi et ne change pas au bout
de six mois je suis méchant parce que je
suis déçu ses
fonctions de
maire mais en fait tu veux qu'ils ont
déjà mais
c'est sérieux la folie père du livre
diction remo commencent à
apparaître sur ces 8 c'est sérieux la
médiatique où c'est une fiction et tu le
fais comme autres à la loi martiale et
aider
je
suis dit est-ce que je peux être que je
me refuse son invention c'est une
attaque
lâche a pas vous attaquer
en arizona sur marie marleix veut
débarrasser de neige
entendu avec les frênes superbe recrue
autour de la table et là
je me suis dit mais non non je reviens
nous est ce que dans la société civile a
fait des choses pour l'intro ordinaire
pour l'égalité alors justement les
discriminations et on lui proposait on
lui proposait elle pense qu'elle peut
aider grâce à son expérience à la barre
fait une carrière politique bien que de
trois ans
sachez apprécier les produits
ce qui fera des mécontents de continuer
mon travail à la sur la conviction je
préfère ça les gens tu vas répondre à
saint paul et la politique c'est
effectivement ça peut être un engagement
un jeu non ça peut être un engagement
j'en ai déjà usé votre engagement et
vous le savez mais ça peut aussi être
des idées à défendre dans toute attaque
serre que ce soit dans les médias radio
par écrit voilà là peu de la politique
c'est pas simplement un vecteur louis
l'engagement partisan dans un parti
politique effectivement c'est faire de
la politique mais c'est pas le seul
comment diable ce n'est pas le seul
engagement qu'on peut avoir on peut
défendre ses idées ailleurs que dans un
parti politique c'est